aloha ho I am bronzed bound and back
from my honeymoon in Hawaii after
marrying sweet little ELISA last week
that's right I'm sorry ladies but I am
now mr. sweet little ELISA take a look
at the ring my bachelor party my wedding
might now full week of experience as a
married man has got me thinking about
manliness at a time when the culture
encourages boys to become girls we will
discuss boys to men from little boys
like Robert DeNiro and Justin Trudeau
all the way to Donald Trump good old men
with a word also on Charles Krauthammer
and his manliness to boot then why I
hops rebranding to the International
House of burgers is a brilliant
marketing strategy directly influenced
by the Trump phenomenon finally it is
pride all the time kappa let's all
celebrate let's celebrate pride all the
time during this all the time it's the
time to celebrate pride we will
celebrate superbia with an historical
retrospective on pride from man's
earliest days I'm Michael Knowles and
this is the Michael Knowles show
[Music]
I have so much to talk to you about I
have missed you so much
and I have simply did anything happen
while I was gone oh yeah everything
we'll get to it before we get to that
got to keep the lights on over here I'm
shocked Ben let me come back I figured
I'd come back to this place and it would
just be rubble but this entire broom
closet that I broadcast from would be
pure rubble and they'd be putting up I
don't know the Ben Shapiro to show or
something and they get me out of here
but thankfully I'm still here and one of
the people we have to thank for that is
blue apron this is very fitting now that
I'm a manly married man you know I have
a way to really eat the blue apron
properly which is having mrs. sweet
little ELISA cook it and people who
apron is really good it is basically all
I eat at home these days obviously I was
on my honeymoon we were eating luaus or
whatever every night but blue apron it
is basically all I eat at home it is so
so good a blue apron delivers farm-fresh
ingredients from and step-by-step
recipes to your door the mission is to
make incredible home cooking accessible
to everyone
blue apron achieves this by supporting a
more sustainable food system highest
standards for ingredients in building a
community of home chefs I got to tell
you the ingredients that come from blue
apron are all top top-notch the meat and
the produce it is all really good it's
about as good as you can get and the
recipes are always great I've never had
a bad recipe from blue apron I've never
had a recipe that I haven't thought oh
that's really good and then what's nice
is once you finish the recipe then you
can go out and just recreate it yourself
because blue apron is constantly
changing the recipes you're not just
gonna get a hamburger every night or
something they're always new they're
really innovative they're so so good you
can get three plans the two-person meal
plan meals that serve two regular people
were one Kevon such as myself you can
choose from eight new recipes per week
with the choice to receive either two or
three recipes any week family meal pant
plan that serves four people or one
Kevon such as myself
you can choose four new recipes per week
and choose receive either two three or
four recipes every week and the wine
plan six bottles of wine from renowned
wine makers that can serve a family or
one gava such as myself all great stuff
convenient flexible really high-quality
check out this week's menu and get your
first three meals for free at blue apron
calm slash cough FA Co V Fe
I know it's my wedding but I'm giving
you a wedding gift blue apron calm / co'
FFA CoV fe fe get your first three meals
free they're extremely delicious blue
apron a better way to cook I've missed
you guys
I've really missed you I actually have
because I was sunning on beautiful
Waikiki and it was really nice made some
friends there I met a great daily wire
listener they're a very cool guy I won't
say his name because I'll lose his job
but it's really good and I'm so I'm
floating around there in Waikiki and I
got to tell you something I actually
sort of missed work I not immediately
and not that much you know but after a
while bobbing along on the ocean it
feels really nice but you do miss
purpose after a while George Bernard
Shaw said that hell is the place where
you have nothing to do but amuse
yourself and so it is it is actually
good to be back I could have used
another few days maybe of just amusing
myself but that's okay it's nice to be
back
I'm also as you can see transracial for
those of you who were just listening I'm
a little bit crispy after my time there
we have finally solved the age-old
question or Sicilians white the answer
is not much of the time and not after
being on the beach this is by the way
after slathering myself in like 60 SPF
constantly and so somehow still pretty
crispy I will give you my thoughts on
marriage my what I've learned in my vast
time as a married man all of the wisdom
I've acquired it turns out marriage is
mostly people giving you a lot of
presents and then eating dinner and
tuxedos and then sunning yourself on a
beach I didn't know that I didn't know
any of that before I got married I
assume it'll keep up like this so so see
how that goes
marriage has me thinking a lot about
manliness because you know look I'm not
exactly a hulking mass of masculinity
I'm not a great Adonis of a man or
something like that I'm not Conan the
Barbarian but in the land of the blind
the one-eyed man is king I've noticed
and so if as me thinking about that in
the early 80s there were a lot more
people getting married
two and a half a million marriage just
happened in the United States every
single year that number is
even though the population has grown
tremendously over that time by hundred
million people or something like that
now just over two million people
two million marriages happen every year
so there's a 40% increase in population
and yet half a million fewer marriages
happen every single year right now the
median age for marriage is 29 so I got
in just under that I'm just under the
median which is good but a lot of people
just don't get married at all so the
median might be 29 but a lot of people
just aren't getting married the Urban
Institute reports that the marriage rate
might drop among Millennials to 70
percent or lower that is way way down
from previous generations the the baby
boomers got married at a rate of 91% the
late boomers who came in the late stage
of the baby boom 87% Gen X 82% that
number drops precipitously for
Millennials if the the present trends
continue so what's that about I think
it's about a crisis of Manliness and all
these attacks on the toxic masculinity
and these bad images we have of what
manliness really is we've totally lost
the sense of manliness in that Harvey
Mansfield kind of way the Aristotelian
kind of way being a gentleman being a
virtuous guy and just to just underscore
the difference between boys and men
little boys becoming men you know it's
so hard to say goodbye to yesterday here
is Robert DeNiro I think he really sums
up that little boy very well I'm gonna
say one thing Trump
it's no longer down with trumpets Jim
that's so brave oh wow Wow sir
that is so brave you said in a room of
Hollywood and New York actors you
attacked a Republican president used a
naughty word Wow oh wow mm gosh finally
an actor behaving like a child
this is what Stanislavski created his
system for this is the American method
it's ridiculous but this is a caricature
of manliness what what Robert De Niro's
doing is actually what little boys do
but it's a caricature of what manliness
is it's a performance of manliness
because Robert De Niro's not a manly guy
he just plays manliness in movies he
plays tough guys in movies in reality he
behaves like a little boy this is the
least courageous thing he could do to
get out there and say the thing that
everybody wants to hear and be just as
vulgar as everybody wants to be and not
add anything to the conversation if if
he had come out and supported Donald
Trump that would have required some
courage right he could be blackballed
from Hollywood as a lot of our friends
have been he could have his show
canceled as some of our friends have had
their shows canceled
you know that would have real
ramifications instead he gets a standing
ovation these people gave him a standing
ovation they applauded him was so oh wow
oh my gosh the I like to start on this
one because it really shows that
difference you know are you the real
thing or are you just part of the show
are you really gonna be the tough guy
you're really gonna be a man or are you
just gonna play act it are you just
gonna try to pretend and be one on TV
I'm not really a doctor I just play one
on TV I'm not really a Robert De Niro's
not really a man he just plays one on TV
one of my favorite news stories that
came out while I was still on my
honeymoon is this Justin Trudeau story
speaking of little boys if Justin
Trudeau did not exist we would have to
invent him of course the wonderful Prime
Minister of Canada who like runs around
in little rainbow booty shorts waving
flags and you know but says that we have
to call criminals and terrorists and
things nice names and all of that so
Justin Trudeau hosted the g7 summit in
the g7 the you know this group of seven
countries basically went well
the thing doesn't mean anything the
g-seven is this group of countries
Canada France Germany Italy Japan the
United Kingdom in the u.s. those those
are the seven countries in and we're all
sort of allies and it was founded in the
70s to work on these big economic
initiatives because in the 70s you had
the the collapse of the exchange rate
the energy crisis recession stagflation
right so there were all these economic
issues and so they decided to bring them
bring all the the finance ministers
together and they would talk about it
and it's blown into this big Hollywood
fest basically but now the heads of
state go and they have a lot of warm and
fuzzy virtue signaling and it has really
veered far away from its original
purpose and it's mostly just a show for
the cameras and to get nice photo ops
here's some evidence of this Justin
Trudeau the the first female Prime
Minister of Canada I think hosted a
coterie think they probably have had
female prime ministers maybe about
Google that will have a producer of
Google that in the meantime Justin
Trudeau hosted a conference on feminism
at the g7 I don't know what that
conference on feminism is going to do
for the global economy or whatever you
know but that's what it's just this
virtue signaling right so he hosts this
women's empowerment feminism conference
and right out of Hollywood scripting
right out of central casting
president Trump shows up late because of
course he does because how can he show
up on time he walks in oh yes sorry I'm
late you know sits next to Christine
Lagarde and Angela Merkel Christine
Lagarde the head of the International
Monetary Fund and Angela Merkel the
woman who single-handedly destroyed
Europe and she's also the Chancellor of
Germany Germany and so he's right there
and by the way there was this picture
that went around and it's very funny
because he comes in late you know in
Merkel's all angry and Christine Lagarde
is being pretty charming and talking to
him and I actually have personal
experience of this because I've
mentioned before that I was a sommelier
at George Soros's wedding this is a
bizarre experience in my life as an
actor I was
cast to be a sommelier at George Soros's
wedding I only found out it was
cirrhosis wedding after the fact after I
was cast in it and so I ended up pouring
wine for christine lagarde
and she was extremely charming and
lovely and she's just a wonderful
politician and really good so she sits
down and she's charming with Trump and
there seem to be getting along and then
you just see Angela Merkel in the corner
like scowling at him and all angry
anyway these little bumps aside the g7
went pretty well it's it's a silly thing
it's not really that important all in
all that went well and so at the end
they all agreed that they would sign on
to this joint statement this communique
on how great everything was it was
boilerplate it was the sort of leftist
whatever but they said they'd all sign
on and then everything fell apart why
why did everything fall apart for
comment we turn to mrs. Broflovski
[Music]
they're not even a real country anyway
America's hat Canada we will explain how
Justin Trudeau blew this thing up hint
spoiler alert it's cuz he's not a man
well get back into that before we do we
get to talk about ring-a-ring is so good
speaking of manliness it's a manly thing
to keep your house and your family and
your wife and your kids safe and your
property safe rings mission is to make
neighborhoods safer today over a million
people use the amazing ring video
doorbell to protect their homes and it's
really good you see all your cool
friends will have this that's how you
know which of your friends are cool guys
I noticed this myself oh my like really
up to date friends had this ring
doorbell and then you click it and a
camera comes on you can talk to
whoever's at the door from wherever you
could be at work or in the home or on a
beach in Waikiki and you can talk to
them if it's a bad guy you can scare
them away
it records everything it uploads it to
the cloud so even if they steal your
ring video doorbell you still got them
you still have that video of them you
can share it to everyone in the
neighborhood and the old days you used
to have a neighborhood watch
that's very time-consuming nobody's got
time for that this is the new way it
makes it much easier and it's a really
great price to get it I love mine just
like rings amazing doorbell they also
have the floodlight camera so it's
motion activated and you know you know
this when you're trying to break into
someone's house and that flood light
comes on ring has one with a camera in
it and so the light comes on instantly
starts recording it's two-way audio HD
video uploads to the cloud is really
excellent technology see and speak to
visitors even set an alarm right from
your phone with rings floodlight camera
when things go bump in the night you'll
immediately know what it is whether
you're home or away the ring a
floodlight cam lets you keep an eye on
your home from anywhere ring offers the
ultimate in home security
with high visibility flood lights a
powerful HD camera that puts security
into your hands this is the thing to get
it's really good I've given it to my
friends I really love this technology
right now don't say never did nothing
for you you can save up to $150 on a
ring home of security kit when you go to
ring.com slash Knolls
KO wles
just like Beyonce go to ring.com slash
Knowles Kano wles just like Beyonce
that is a ring.com slash Knowles canter
wles like Beyonce
so Justin Trudeau blew up this g7 summit
and he blew it up because he's not a man
that's why that manliness is actually
the issue here it wasn't really the
tariffs it wasn't really sniping over
trade it's because Justin Trudeau is a
little boy cuz he's a little girly man
everything was fine everyone had agreed
Donald Donald Trump has been trying to
negotiate with tariffs with tariffs that
Canada is putting on the United States
in the United States could put on Canada
for a long time now larry cudlow trump
economic adviser negotiated with Trudeau
personally and then Justin Trudeau holds
this press conference and makes this
statement I have made it very clear to
the president that it is not something
we relish doing but it is something that
we absolutely will do because Canadians
were polite were reasonable but we also
will not be pushed around
okay now the I kind of get if you see
this you'd say oh that's not so bad
he's saying Trump can't push him around
and why is this so bad why is this so
bad because it's this caddy bratty mean
girl
backstabbing deception this is not the
way allies behave you know people are
saying about Donald Trump they're saying
Trump is being mean to our allies that's
not how allies should be Justin Trudeau
is not how allies should behave they had
come to an agreement
they were at the g7 they had negotiated
about reducing certain tariffs that
Canada is imposing on us goods and in
exchange for concessions from the United
States on trade and they agreed and then
they're gonna go out and have this nice
communique and everything's all
hunky-dory and then he comes out he says
but you're not gonna push us around
Donald Trump you're not gonna push us
around
I bet he didn't say that to Donald
Trump's face I mean he didn't say that -
Larry Cutler's face did he know I bet -
his face he said oh hey how about we all
go out and sign this communique a I bet
that's what he said to his face and then
he goes out because he's a little little
boy and and stabs him in the back it
really this is not some conservatives
right now or
saying oh come on we want free trade
nobody wants tariffs it wasn't that bad
Yatta Yatta Yatta don't be so harsh on
him because of course that the Trump
aids came out and they said Peter
Navarro a trump aide said that there's a
special place in hell reserved for
Justin Trudeau for stabbing him in the
back you know and the Kudlow came out
and attacked him so they're saying oh
it's not that bad come on stop it
no that is bad that is really bad the
United States should not be pushed
around by Justin Trudeau is and we're
not gonna tolerate that that's absurd
because by the way Donald Trump is in
the right here in the negotiation you
weren't nobody wants a trade war nobody
wants massive tariffs the left and the
Trump critics on the right are trying to
pretend like Donald Trump and his
supporters want massive tariffs on goods
to hike everybody's taxes nobody wants
that nobody wants that but right now as
the president pointed out as Larry
Kudlow pointed out Canada has dairy
tariffs on United States dairy upwards
of two hundred seventy percent possibly
upwards of two hundred ninety five
percent that is those are huge tariffs
we can't tolerate that and then the
minute that we say that we're going to
retaliate they say you're starting a
trade war you store them - the trade war
or maybe there isn't a trade war and
maybe we're just negotiating on trade as
nations tend to do of course but what
Justin Trudeau does is he says I'm gonna
get my last minute snipe in when it's
too late for Donald Trump to respond
yeah I'm gonna get that you know it's
like when you're arguing with a child
and they just have to get the last word
you say okay alright we've resolved this
they say yeah yeah you mmm you say well
why'd you have to do that at the end
that's not how adults behave and it's
really awful the timing is really awful
because we're going into this Kym summit
we're going into the Kim jeong-min North
Korea summit and he gets this
last-minute snipe in at the president
and and I'm really glad that Trump
responded in the way he did he said okay
you want to get your little snipe in
we're not gonna sign on to the
communique I hope you I hope you enjoyed
your your vacation in Canada I hope you
enjoyed the g7 but we're not gonna
tolerate this good we absolutely
shouldn't tolerate this it's an
important point about manliness because
a
people think that the the we just need
everyone to like us that's what that's
what men want but that's what little
boys want going into this this summit so
look at look at Angela Merkel for a
second we've got Angela Merkel leaning
over the Chancellor of Germany
single-handed destroyer of Europe she's
leaning over angry at Trump and then in
that same photo you've got Trump and
Bolton and eBay of Japan just arms
crossed not budging just not Trump
staring a right back in her face at
Merkel Angela Merkel flooded Europe with
millions of lightly vetted or totally
unvetted Muslim immigrants meanwhile
crimes rapes terror attacks are surging
all across Europe they're covering it up
and work will allow them to flood she
has no credibility here she's not gonna
tell us how to run our country had a run
global trade and globalization she's
used globalization to help destroy her
continent she has and I'm glad thank
goodness that we have a president who's
gonna say no you've done a terrible job
leading your continent and and maybe my
predecessor let you do it but I'm not
gonna let you do it but you know it was
going around Twitter that photo alone is
basically worth the trump presidency
we've gotten a lot of other good stuff
too but I love it just staring Europe in
the face the face of mass migration open
borders Europe and saying no no more
this gets to the central premise here
how the left sees the world had a right
sees the world and specifically how they
see manliness will explain why the right
is right before we do that I couldn't do
that if I didn't have shiny teeth could
I I couldn't I wouldn't be as convincing
if I had just just gummy you know rotten
teeth or something like that and that's
why you need to use an electronic
toothbrush like quip quip is so so good
when it comes to your health brushing
your teeth is one of the most important
parts of your day and you should
probably do it multiple times a day
if you once sweet little ELISA to kiss
you then you have to press your teeth
more than once a day
quip knows that they've combined
dentistry and design to make a better
electric toothbrush quip is the new
electric toothbrush that packs just the
right amount of vibrations into a
slimmer design at a fraction of the cost
of bulkier traditional electric
Rush's it's super sleek you can travel
with it the clip-on case that you can
store it in your bathroom it becomes a
travel case super convenient really nice
product guiding pulses alert you when to
switch sides which makes brushing the
right amount of time effortless you know
in my in my horrible bachelor days when
I brush my teeth and be like I take like
a stick from the woods I go all right
throw it out you know but this you know
you're supposed to brush for a certain
amount of time on each side quit to let
you know how long to do it because the
thing that cleans your mouth should also
be clean Equipe subscription plan
refreshes your brush on a dentist
recommended schedule delivers a new
brush head every three months for just
five bucks new brush heads every three
months just five dollars that is really
easy free shipping worldwide you don't
need to go to the store is that we'd
never go to the drugstore to buy a new
toothbrush I would that would be like a
semi biannual event probably I'd go
every couple of years it's backed by a
network of over 10,000 dental
professionals including dentists
hygienists and dental students most
toothbrushes don't get named times
Magazine's best inventions of the year
but quit did to find out why for
yourself quip starts at just 25 bucks
and if you've got equipped out and get
quip comm slash Knowles kano wles right
now you will get your first refill pack
for free with a quip electric toothbrush
that is your first refill pack for free
at get quip comm slash Knowles kena wles
that is spelled I bet you can guess how
to spell it but I'll spell it for you
anyway I'll spell it all out GE t qu IP
comm slash Knowles ke n o WL e s go over
and do itno w period ri ght and o w
period so okay we got a I've got more to
talk about but I do want to wrap up this
manliness point because it's really
embodied here in mr. Trudeau the left is
looking at this g7 summit and and
president Trump's handling of Justin
Trudeau in particular you're saying oh
no our friends hate us oh no because
little boys are desperate for the
affirmation of others and grown men just
do the right thing they just do what
needs to be done and they don't need to
be affirmed constantly in
whatever they're doing right which isn't
to say that we want to be despised men
don't want to like be hated or something
like that but men which is something we
we should aspire to be men don't care
about affirmation as the number-one goal
the left keeps saying that the u.s. is
isolating itself from the world it's
probably cuz they're watching CNN so
they they only see that fantasy that's
absurd
right now around the world Isis has been
defeated militarily Israel is building
train stations dedicated to the
president in the United States Iran's
path to nuclear weapons have been slowed
down even France likes us even France
for goodness sake the flag of the French
army Emmanuel macron likes Donald Trump
likes our president comes on over here
says nice things about us you know
little boys they can't say no but grown
men have to say no sometimes and
sometimes we have to say no to our
partners Donald Trump ran on getting
NATO allies to start paying anything for
protection of you know for our military
protection past presidents have demanded
that - they've begged for it Donald
Trump is the only one who accomplished
it he accomplished it by being firm
we're having a summit with North Korea
now we're having this remember that
summit was off we're never gonna get it
Trump's gonna blow up the world isn't it
and now we've got it and by the way you
know I've been gone a long time so maybe
I missed this as the mainstream media
apologized for its coverage of the Kim
summit and with the on-again-off-again
summit W treat President Trump and kim
jeong-hoon on the rocks at least for now
what happens to that commemorative coin
minted in preparation here in the United
States there you see it you see the
president Kim Jong loon the North Korean
flag the US flag that's the coin that
was all ready for the summit what
happens to it now we have details
when news broke today that President
Trump had canceled the summit with Kim
jong-un there was a mad rush to a White
House website not for more information
about Trump's decision but of course
she's a gift shop for the commemorative
summit coins where lo and behold the
coins had been designated the deal of
the day
selling for the low low price of just
1995 and thank goodness the shop had
posted a disclaimer to dispel any
concerns about the fate of the coins
true Trump fashion written with almost
but not quite all the words
unnecessarily capitalized and missing
some punctuation saying the coin will be
made whether or not the whether or not
the summit occurs as scheduled because
the theme is coming closer to peace and
celebrates the act of communication
among countries if summit does not occur
you can request a refund but most
supporters have said they want this
heirloom of political history its
outcome I cannot believe someone wrote
that and then for the piece de
resistance the page couldn't handle the
volume of visitors and crashed remaining
down for several hours isn't that funny
isn't that so funny isn't it you know
what's really funny about that whole
segment is it's entirely fake news
because there is no such thing as a
White House gift shop that's why that's
why it's fake news that well there is a
White House gift shop there is a company
called the White House gift shop that
has no connection to the current White
House it's but they're giddy aren't they
they're so giddy on CNN MSNBC so funny
hahaha it's funny for two reasons the
mainstream media reaction to this
because they say oh you know the White
House gift shop made this coin and then
the summit got canceled so now the coin
is pointless hahaha isn't it so funny
that we won't have a denuclearization
summit now and hopefully bring more
stability and peace to the world
hahaha that'll show Trump ha ha ha right
so that and but and now it's funny
because you know it's happening and they
were totally wrong and they were so they
were so excited that we might not do
nuclearized North Korea they were
praying that North Korea would still get
to keep their nuclear weapons and then
the summit's back on but to the other
reason why it's really funny is that the
White House never issued a coin it never
issued a coin at all this is like
percent manufactured fake news there is
a company called the White House gift
shop which is located in Lititz
Pennsylvania
it is a private for-profit company it's
owned by some guy named Anthony Giannini
just some guy is not a White House
official is just a dude there there you
do used to be a gift shop associated
with the White House but for at least
the last seven years there's just this
private company with a website run out
of Pennsylvania actual fake news so
little boys like Chris Hayes little mean
girls so desperate to attack Donald
Trump that they'd make up a story whole
cloth they celebrate canceling this
denuclearization summit even though it's
still on what's the point of all this
what's the goal this is another big
difference between the little boys and
men adults grownups what's the goal here
what's the point of all this stuff
little boys are motivated
disproportionately by base impulses sex
drugs and rock and roll fame power and
money it's all the same thing is base
fleshy impulses men are after something
higher than that something more
long-lasting than that which is
accomplishment something beyond just
pleasing the senses for a little bit of
time for an actual accomplishment Donald
Trump was asked you know are you gonna
get the Nobel Peace Prize if you
denuclearize Korea and he joked about it
he said oh you know a lot of people are
saying I should but I don't care about
that what's more important is getting it
done and I think he meant that earnestly
and part of the reason I think he meant
that is that getting a Nobel Peace Prize
is absolutely meaningless I mean you
know Obama got one after being president
for fifty seconds or something it
doesn't mean anything so so I you know
that I really am pleased that we have an
administration that is focused on
accomplishment and all these little boys
who want to tiki-tiki and spread fake
news that's fine you can keep it up but
in in the meantime the real men are
gonna go do work in the world and
actually make America great again
little little boys can't make America
great again only only a real grown-up
men can okay we have got to get to the
Internet International House of
breakfast do I have to sign off I gotta
sign off oh man oh this that's too bad
because the International House of
breakfast is one of the most brilliant
marketing strategies in a long time and
it actually is downstream
this exuberance on the right and this
Trump phenomenon will explain how I'll
also talk about pride and I'll say a
little bit on Charles Krauthammer whom I
admire immensely before that I got to
say goodbye to Facebook and YouTube
Facebook and YouTube go over to Daily
wire calm right now it's ten bucks a
month or $100 for an annual membership
you get me you get the end or Clavin
sure you get the Ben Shapiro show you
get to ask questions in the mailbag you
get to ask questions in the conversation
by the way we're gonna be hosting a
little Father's Day gathering tomorrow
Tuesday June 12th at 7 p.m. Eastern
special livestream in honor of Father's
Day The Daily wire God king himself
Jeremy boring will host a roundtable
discussion with me Andrew Clavin Ben
Shapiro and special guests so Rachel and
Nick Searcy the International film and
television stars Nick Searcy to discuss
the role of the father in our society
we'll be live-streaming on Facebook and
YouTube if you're a daily wire
subscriber go to daily wire.com to
submit live questions to us which will
be moderated by the one and only lovely
Alicia Kraus again that is tomorrow
Tuesday June 12th 7 p.m. Eastern 4:00
Pacific don't miss it we will be right
back go to daily wire calm
[Music]
you know I was shipping a lot of drinks
out of coconuts and pineapples last week
but this is the most delicious one of
all hmm oh how I have missed you left us
tears tumblr I have mmm that tastes a
little bit like gum who was that guy in
casino and Goodfellas yeah oh yeah the
Robert De Niro vintage mmm delish delish
okay we only have a little bit of time
left so I want to get to International
House of Pancakes becoming International
House of burgers I hop is i hob this is
a marketing reaction to the Trump
phenomenon and it is really great even
the reaction to it mirrors what's
happening in politics the consensus view
of this I hop thing is that it's crazy
and terrible and it's so stupid and
awful
in reality it's working quite well
because the consensus view is almost
always wrong this is you know you can
this is how people make money in the
stock market right the consensus view is
almost always wrong and people who see
how it's wrong can succeed so here's the
consensus view whenever companies and
people stop doing the thing that made
them successful and they start
pretending to be something else that
never works out well you know you got
new coke and and Crystal Pepsi and do
you remember Arby's tried to be a
healthy sandwich place for like five
seconds that was just terrible and then
they went back to we have the meats and
now it's good again Rubio pretended to
be Donald Trump in 2016 he did that
Rickles shtick it didn't work John Kerry
pretended to be cool that time you know
and also we're hearing now that reports
are coming out all the time that
authenticity matters in marketing and so
what is IHOP doing there not a burger
place have you ever eaten a burger at
IHOP no so the consensus view is that
this is a terrible idea this is a great
strategy that view is totally wrong you
probably can't remember the last time
you had a burger at IHOP you also
probably can't remember the last time
you ate at IHOP and you certainly can't
remember the last time you talked at
IHOP I talked about IHOP rather you
probably can't remem the last time you
talked to ad it either because it's like
primo drunk end of night food so things
get a little blurry at that point
here it's a gimmick right I hop is
serves breakfast and lunch people only
know of it as a pancake place and they
want to let people know that they also
serve lunch this is a fun light and
apparently crazy marketing stunt they're
not actually going to remain a hub
that's just a marketing thing we have
been talking about I hop for days it has
been a top trend on Twitter for days at
this point this is a shrewd marketing
advisor watching our culture and it's a
big shift in how marketing is happening
in the Obama days marketing was all
about virtue signaling right you
remember the famously target changing
its bathroom policies that was really
about marketing saying we're a
progressive company come to work
progress we're really nice Chipotle the
food the restaurant Chipotle would
they'd always say oh we use organic
local high quality rice or whatever
right that was their marketing gimmick
it's all sustainable good for the world
social entrepreneurship TOMS shoes you
know they make cheap shoes and they
donate a pair of shoes to charity when
you overpay for these shoes and that
right and it's so tedious it's so
tedious that virtue signaling the Obama
model of politics is so tedious all that
to be a good person you have to mmm-hmm
right and then the Trump model of
politics is act wild break things and
have fun and that's what I hop is doing
it's really smart it's a lot of fun I
mean that's a pretty wild thing to say
we're gonna totally change our name and
we're gonna make it this whimsical
bizarre apparently out-of-left-field
name it's really big and it's really
bold but what could go wrong we've been
talking about them for days and people
are probably gonna go to IHOP now and
they're probably gonna order pancakes
listen I want you to be the pancake
house again so I'm gonna order pancakes
despite you and they'll say oh gosh
you're really showing us counting the
money right putting in the cash register
really good speaking of bad marketing
let's talk about Pride Month to begin is
any month not Pride Month now I think
June is technically Pride Month but
there were also major Pride days and
events in in January February March
April May June July August September
October November December every single
month there are major pride events in
the United States this began in 1968
when
when a gay activist created the slogan
gay is good and the idea here was it was
mirroring Stokely Carmichael's black is
beautiful
so the gay is good and that strategy
makes sense to me is the argument gay is
good is much more compelling than pride
is good right
the argument gay is good basically says
you have this moral structure from
Judaism or Christianity or Islam or the
sort of traditions of the West
and you have this moral structure that
says that gay relationships broadly
aren't good gay sexual relationships and
we're saying that it is good and here's
why and that or you could follow that's
a fair argument but but the argument
pride is good I don't know that anyone
actually makes that they're just saying
it but no one really believes that st.
Thomas following st. Gregory's lead
considered pride pardon the pun the
queen of all sins so fried is the
excessive love of one's own excellence
it's the parent of all sins Eve eats the
Apple to be as a God Adam eats the Apple
to pride does not turn out very well and
how his pride turned out this Pride
Month recently a CrossFit employee
Russell burger was fired for criticizing
celebrations of pride maybe he can get a
job at IHOP mmm the CEO of CrossFit Greg
Glassman he called burger a zealot and
he said that he needs to take a big dose
of shut the F up that was with the CEO
of CrossFit said about his fired
employee because his fired employee said
I don't support pride I think pride is a
sin I'm a Christian and I think that the
pride agenda has become very intolerant
of other people's views and the CEO of
that company said what you think it's
intolerant well now you're fired that'll
show you how to tolerate we are s okay
there's Jack Phillips that Colorado
Baker who had his livelihood destroyed
for not wanting to participate in
something that he considers a perversion
of marriage and a sin a baron l Stutzman
in washington florists same thing jack
dorsey the head of twitter jack know
conservative by the way pretty left-wing
guy he went to chick-fil-a and he ate
sandwich and he tweeted out a picture
and he said this was a good chicken
sandwich people attacked him viciously
Soledad O'Brien said oh this is son this
is a pretty weird thing to tweet out on
Pride Month and Jackson I'm sorry I'm
sorry I I didn't mean to say I liked the
chicken sandwich it wasn't that good it
was a little spicy man right it's just
absurd it there's a great irony here
because the gay pride movement began
after gay people were having their bars
raided and you know were were arrested
for their sexual practices and all this
and they were the suppressed group right
and now now what's happened it's totally
flipped the pride is the mainstream
culture every company is doing pride
events if you don't tow the line you're
gonna get fired you're gonna have your
reputation ruined and if people say you
know my religion tells me that I
shouldn't celebrate pride the original
sin you could have your your livelihood
ruined that's that's the underdog it's
an amazing inversion and pride is very
insidious people don't usually know when
it's affecting them so you know these
people who were pushing this agenda the
CEO of CrossFit who fires his employee
he probably thinks he's the good guy but
he isn't the good guy and so I never
understood why pride became the title
for the gay rights movement it's a it's
a stupid title they had a much better
idea of an argument 50 years ago and as
long as it's pride it's hard to
celebrate pride because pride is always
terrible the last before we go I know
we're running a little on the later side
but I've got to talk about Charles
Krauthammer uh you saw that this
actually really bummed me out on my
honeymoon I was trying to avoid the news
and this was such breaking news Charles
Krauthammer wrote an incredible
beautiful note in which he said that my
doctors have told me I have weeks to
leave to live my fight is over I've
lived the life I intended to live and I
leave this life with no regrets thank
you to everyone who's given my life its
work significance and see you see you
next time you know and it was really
moving
he obviously wrote it much better than I
just paraphrased it because he's a
brilliant writer and thinker and it
really bummed me out because I love
Charles Krauthammer and Charles
Krauthammer is and not a conservative in
a really ideological sense he was a
speechwriter for Walter Mondale he's an
incredibly important writer conservative
intellectual but you know I don't think
he chose the party line in in many ways
he's incredible thinker he was such an
important voice I would always read his
columns and all of the the memorials are
coming out for grad amber now he's lived
a really good life he did what he wanted
to do the thing I want to point out is
one of his columns so that really spoke
to me and told me what to think and it
really made me understand what a
sophisticated thinker he is and it was
when they were gonna build that mosque
at Ground Zero this was happening I
think around 2010 there was this
movement to build an Islamic Center is
what it was called by the supporters of
it and a mosque is what it was called in
reality at Ground Zero in the financial
district of New York and this was seen
as just a horrible affront to people who
saw Muslims in the name of Islam knocked
down those Twin Towers and kill
thousands of American civilians and
there you had people like Mike Bloomberg
coming out who was sort of a Republican
sort of a Democrat and he said they
should build the mosque free speech
freedom of religion they should build a
mosque right on the grave sites
basically you know it's they should
build it wherever they want and there
was a good argument there because we
have no establishment of religion it's a
free country you know but then there was
this this gut feeling where you felt
gosh that just seems awful they just
they just they shouldn't do it and
Charles Krauthammer was the guy who made
me understand why it why it was not a
good idea to build that mosque there he
made me understand how to articulate
that he wrote in his column on that
Center quote America is a free country
where you can build whatever you want
but not anywhere that's why we have
zoning laws no liquor store near a
school no strip malls where they offend
local sensibilities and if your house
doesn't meet community architectural
codes you cannot build at all these
restrictions are for reasons of
aesthetics others are for more profound
reasons of common decency and respect
for the sacred no commercial tower over
Gettysburg no Khan
- wits and no mosque at Ground Zero
build it anywhere but there the governor
of New York offered to help find lamb to
build the mosque elsewhere a mosque
really seeking to build bridges Rossa
sensible hope for the structure would
accept the offer but of course it wasn't
trying to build bridges at all it was
trying to be divisive and make a
political statement and they and a very
awful political statement a Krauthammer
in talking about common decency and
respect for the sacred he really spoke
to something that I think the
ideological conservatives miss out on
sometimes where they just basically
recite the Constitution in their sleep
and they kind of forget where that
Constitution Springs from but Charles
Krauthammer is a man of deep learning
and deep wisdom and thought he's I think
vaguely agnostic he doesn't ascribe to
any particular religion but he also said
that atheism is the least plausible
theology of them all I think he once
said I don't believe in God but I fear
him and I had the privilege of meeting
him on two occasions and he was always
graceful and funny and profound and
thoughtful in his in what he was saying
and we're really gonna miss that I think
he's basically without a peer in
political commentary and political
thought today and we're just really
gonna miss him he's a he's a great
thinker and writer and and even as he
prepares to meet his maker and he does
have a maker and it's a good thing that
he fears that maker and only fear and
awe but even as he prepares to do that
he doesn't in such a in such a manly way
to talk about our main theme from
today's show he he looks fate right in
the eye and he says I'm ready for this
this life to come to an end I did I
didn't create this life for myself I've
warmed it how I want it to be formed and
to develop and if this is what's coming
now I have no regrets it's really a
really beautiful thing and we're gonna
miss Charles Krauthammer so we read him
while he's still here and send out all
your nice tweets to him because he's a
really really great thinker okay on that
note getting you know I Drew was talking
about this on his show - a little bit I
don't
to care that much when celebrities die
it's now you know I'm a part of humanity
and all all deaths
you know diminish me and all that but I
I cry hammer in particular he's really
gonna be missed okay that's our show I'm
Michael Knowles's the Michael Nolt show
we have some amazing guests coming up
this week be sure to tune in I'll see
you tomorrow
[Music]
the Michael Nolt show is produced by
seniya Villarreal executive producer
Jeremy boring senior producer Jonathan
hey our supervising producer
Mathis Glover and our technical producer
is Austin Stevens edited by Jim nickel
audio is mixed by mic core Amina hair
and makeup is by Jessa alvera the
Michael Knowles oh is a daily wire for
word publishing production copyright for
word publishing 2018
you